The forces of healing,
reconciliation and shared interest
that have inspired the construction of Europe
are today increasingly transforming
the economic and political landscape
of the island of Ireland.
My visit here to the European Parliament
comes at a time of great hope and optimism
on the island of Ireland.
For the first time in a generation,
it is free of paramilitary violence.
It is right to express here in this city,
so symbolic of the spirit of European reconciliation,
deep appreciation for the consistent
and unwavering support of the European Union.
Unemployment and poverty are like poisons
which attack the social fabric.
Failure to devise and implement radical solutions
to these problems undermines confidence.
With power comes responsibility.
And as a corollary to the importance
and influence in the world,
the Union is bound to exercise those powers
in a responsible fashion.
We owe it to those much less fortunate than ourselves
to provide the means with which they can be freed
from the debilitating cycle of war,
famine and disease.
It is incumbent on us to ensure
that the causes and consequences of hunger and suffering
in the developing world are properly addressed.
The old certainties have vanished
with the collapse of communism,
a unique historical opportunity has presented itself.
However, it is also important that relations with Russia
should be based on respect for human rights
and the principles of the United Nations and the OSCE.
I am keenly aware
that members of this body
are working with foresight and commitment
to build a permanent Europe!
Thank you for giving me this opportunity to address you.